Traductor: Judit Rodríguez
Revisor: Manuel Bas y Mansilla
Vivimos mejor que nunca.
Gracias a los avances científicos,
la tecnología, las telecomunicaciones,
tenemos actualmente la condición de vida
como si fuéramos dioses del Olimpo.
Pensadlo bien: si deseamos algo,
simplemente con mover un dedo
podemos tener en nuestra casa
comida exótica de muchos lugares,
podemos abrir ventanas
a sitios muy distantes,
o podemos transmitir nuestra voz
y nuestra imagen a estos lugares.
O incluso, moviendo un simple dedo,
podemos adquirir billetes para viajar
a cualquier lugar del mundo
por tierra, mar o aire.
Verdaderamente tenemos un poder
como el de los mismísimos dioses.
Sin embargo, hay un problema:
hay un precio a pagar
para tener todo esto.
Toda la tecnología, todo lo que
somos capaces de producir,
de diseñar, de compartir, de poseer,
depende de una variable, que
no siempre tenemos en cuenta
y que es fundamental para que todo
funcione, que es la energía.
Aunque resulte sorprendente
lo que les voy a decir ahora
estamos ahora mismo, en 2018, inmersos
en una grave crisis energética global
que se está manifestando
de muchas maneras.
Y este es el problema que tendremos
que afrontar los próximos años
porque si no, nuestra propia civilización
podría acabar siendo destruida.
El problema que tenemos ahora mismo
es que las fuentes
de energía no renovable
que son el petróleo, el carbón,
el gas natural y el uranio
están llegando a su máximo de producción,
si no han pasado ya de este punto
y por lo que hacen las energías
renovables, como luego veremos,
no van a ser capaces de cubrir
el inmenso agujero que dejan estas detrás.
Tenemos que pensar que el problema
que estoy describiendo
no es como si alguien encendiera
y apagara un interruptor.
No es que tenemos
toda la energía del mundo hoy
y mañana dejamos de tenerla.
No, la cuestión es que
entraremos en un proceso de declive
en el cual cada año tendremos
un poco menos de energía
que el año anterior
y tendremos que pasar con eso.
Es esencialmente que se nos va a ir
reduciendo progresivamente
el sueldo energético
con el cual estamos viviendo.
Veamos algunos datos.
En el año 2005, aproximadamente,
la producción de petróleo
crudo convencional
llegó a su máximo histórico.
El petróleo crudo convencional
es el petróleo de toda la vida
que se extrae como se ha extraído
el petróleo siempre.
¿Habéis visto estos pozos de petróleo
que salen en las películas
que son como un martillo gigante
que sube y baja, cabeceando?
Pues ese es el petróleo
crudo convencional.
Es el petróleo más fácil de extraer
y también el que tiene más calidad
es el que permite hacer más cosas.
Evidentemente, a medida
que nos hemos ido quedando
con este progresivo agotamiento,
en el año 2005, como dije,
llegamos al máximo,
que fue de 70 millones de barriles
diarios y ahora ya estamos por los 67
y por lo que se ve, va a seguir bajando,
hemos tenido que poner
otras cosas, otras sustancias,
otros hidrocarburos líquidos
que son sucedáneos,
que hacen, más o menos,
las veces del petróleo para sustituirlo.
Estos otros líquidos del petróleo
son sustancias diversas
poco relacionadas realmente
con el petróleo,
por ejemplo, los líquidos que salen
cuando extraes el gas natural
que, básicamente,
la mayoría es butano y es propano;
o bien es el alcohol
y los aceites refinados
que obtenemos de los vegetales,
lo que muchas veces
se denomina biocombustibles;
o bien es una especie de alquitrán,
de brea, que se extrae mezclado con arena
en los bosques espesos
de Canadá y de Venezuela,
los petróleos extrapesados
que luego se procesan para tener
algo parecido al petróleo;
o bien la joya del momento,
la gran revolución energética, dicen,
que es el petróleo de fracking
que se extrae sobre todo en EE.UU.
y esencialmente consiste
en coger la roca, fracturarla,
romperla de mil maneras
para intentar extraer
las pequeñas gotitas que están
por aquí y por allá dispersas.
Juntando todas estas fuentes de energía
de los carburos líquidos alternativos,
que son mucho más difíciles de extraer
y tienen mucha menos calidad
lo que podemos conseguir es incrementar
la producción total de petróleo
pero al final nos estamos
moviendo en un 10-12 %
que conseguimos gracias
a estos hidrocarburos adicionales
y el 90 % prácticamente sigue siendo
el petróleo convencional,
y no estamos siendo capaces de compensar
la caída cada vez mayor
del petróleo crudo convencional.
Y lo peor es que si uno
hace caso a las estimaciones
de la Agencia Internacional de la Energía
para los próximos años,
la tendencia va a continuar a la baja
de manera muy sostenida.
Vamos a tener cada vez menos petróleo
para hacer las cosas.
Si uno lee la prensa económica,
lo que dicen los analistas económicos,
piensan que poniendo
más dinero sobre la mesa
las petroleras pueden desarrollar
más yacimientos de hidrocarburos
cuando en realidad está pasando
exactamente lo contrario.
Desde el año 2014, fundamentalmente,
las compañías petroleras están quedándose
con los yacimientos más rentables
y abandonan los que no son rentables
porque los yacimientos de petróleo
que van quedando son los peores,
los que realmente no dan dinero,
y no quieren arruinarse.
Esto está pasando en todos
los países del mundo,
con la única excepción de EE.UU.
En EE. UU. gracias al fracking,
que ha aumentado enormemente
la producción de ese país,
prácticamente la ha duplicado,
ellos han creído que pueden llegar a ser
energéticamente independientes.
Esta es la moto que le han vendido
al Sr. Trump y que ha comprado.
Lo malo es que es una moto muy mala.
Porque aparte del daño ambiental
que genera el fracking,
el problema es que los pozos
duran muy poco.
Un pozo de fracking típicamente
produce el 80 % de todo el petróleo
que producirá en su vida
en los dos primeros años.
Mientras que un pozo
de petróleo convencional
dura aproximadamente 20 años
antes de llegar a ese punto.
Duran poco y además, producen muy poco.
Necesitas 200 pozos de fracking
para que equivalga a la producción
de un pozo de petróleo convencional.
Duran poco y además resulta
que son ruinosos económicamente,
se pierde dinero explotando
el petróleo de fracking.
Como alertaba el Departamento de Energía
de EE.UU. en julio de 2014,
las 127 compañías de petróleo y de gas
más importantes del mundo
estaban perdiendo dinero al ritmo de
unos 110.000 millones de dólares cada año
entre los años 2011 y 2014,
que es lo que represento en la
gráfica que ven aquí detrás.
La línea azul representa
el gasto de estas compañías,
y la línea verde los ingresos.
La diferencia es de unos
110.000 millones de dólares
hasta julio del año 2014.
Y eso ha pasado en el período
en el que el precio medio del petróleo,
ha sido el más alto de la historia.
Imaginaos la cantidad de dinero
que deben perder
ahora que los balances contables
de la mayoría de las petroleras del mundo
están en números rojos
desde hace unos cuantos años.
Esto con lo que respecta al petróleo.
¿Pero qué pasa con las otras fuentes?
En cuanto al carbón,
parece ser que ya hemos llegado
al máximo de producción de carbón
y estamos empezando el proceso de declive.
Con el uranio, estamos más o menos ahí,
no parece que vaya a tardar mucho más
y el gas natural es la única fuente
no renovable que parece que todavía
puede ascender un poco
durante los próximos años,
pero en cualquier caso, se está calculando
que llegará a su máximo de producción
antes del año 2030, quizá antes incluso
si empezamos a utilizarlo más
para compensar la pérdida de los otros.
Con lo cual, pensad que tenemos
un problema bastante serio.
Las fuentes no renovables,
que son el petróleo, el carbón,
el gas natural y el uranio,
que representan el 91 % de toda la energía
que se consume actualmente en el mundo,
empieza su proceso de retirada,
de declive,
van a ir disminuyendo
nuestro sueldo energético,
lo que implica que tendremos que vivir
cada vez con menos energía,
así que tendremos que consumir
cada vez menos energía,
y por tanto tendremos que,
en general, consumir menos.
Algo que en una economía capitalista,
el hecho de consumir menos,
sería bastante malo,
genera crisis económicas y desempleo.
El problema del declive
de las fuentes de energía no renovables
no se puede atribuir
al ascenso de las energías renovables,
porque no es lo que han ascendido,
no es lo que representan hoy en día.
Es un problema que tiene más
que ver con la ciencia.
Es lo que nos dice la geología,
que básicamente es
cómo son los yacimientos,
y lo que nos dice la física,
concretamente una rama de la física
que es la termodinámica,
que es la rama de la física
que más se parece a una madre
porque te prohíbe
todo aquello que es divertido.
(Risas)
Los tres principios en los que
se fundamenta la termodinámica,
habréis oído hablar de ellos,
son el primero, segundo y tercero,
no tenemos nombres más originales.
Básicamente, se pueden resumir así:
el primero te dice que no puedes ganar,
el segundo te dice que no puedes empatar
y el tercero te dice que
no puedes dejar el juego.
Y esta es la situación
con la explotación de cualquier mineral,
no solo los energéticos.
Tú puedes encontrarlos,
descubrirlos, explotarlos, aprovecharlos,
pero a medida que el tiempo va pasando,
la cantidad que puedes explotar
va decreciendo,
tienes que aceptar que llega
un momento inevitable
en el que el yacimiento se va muriendo
y tienes cada vez menos
de ese juguete con el que querías jugar.
¿Qué pasa con las energías renovables?
Sabemos que las energías no renovables
hay que empezar a abandonarlas,
no instantáneamente,
porque es un proceso de décadas,
pero aquí tenemos las renovables
para salvar el día.
Podemos conseguir mucha energía
gracias al viento, al agua, a la solar...
Pues quizá no tanto,
de acuerdo con los estudios
del Grupo de Dinámica de Sistemas
de la Universidad de Valladolid,
que luego ha sido corroborado por
otros grupos por toda Europa,
parece que la máxima cantidad
de energía renovable
que podemos llegar a aprovechar,
-y eso haciendo las cosas bien-
sería aproximadamente un 30 % de lo que
se consume hoy en día en el mundo.
Es verdad que hay otros autores,
como Mark Jacobson o Mark Delucchi,
que afirman que podríamos llegar
a producir el 100 % e incluso algo más.
Sin embargo, el trabajo de Jacobson
ha sido muy contestado
porque hay bastantes defectos
en las hipótesis que hace,
y yo pertenezco a una mayoría
que cree que lo más sensato
es pensar que si hacemos las cosas bien
nos podemos quedar en ese
30 % de todo el consumo.
Que es muchísimo, posiblemente
uno puede cubrir perfectamente
las necesidades de toda la humanidad
con ese 30 % de energía.
Lo que pasa, y esto es una cosa que se
deduce de todos los estudios científicos,
porque no hay nadie dentro
de la comunidad científica
que diga que con un sistema
de energías renovables
uno va a poder seguir creciendo.
El crecimiento es una cosa del pasado,
se acabo.
No solo dicen eso,
que el crecimiento es imposible
con un sistema de energías renovables,
sino que además, lo que nos dicen
es que vamos a tener que hacer un gran
esfuerzo en los próximos 30, 40 o 50 años,
establecer un sistema
de economía de guerra
simplemente para hacer una
transformación eficaz
de nuestro sistema económico,
energético y social,
para adaptarnos al cambio que necesitamos.
Y este proceso lo vamos a tener que hacer
en una situación muy complicada
en la que además, los materiales
que vamos a necesitar
pueden empezar a escasear.
¿Qué pasa con el resto
de investigación en energías?
¿No pueden encontrarse otros sistemas
energéticos que pudieran salvar el día?
Ahí está el ITER, para hacer
la fusión nuclear caliente,
hay gente que trabaja
la fusión nuclear fría,
gente que trabaja con materiales
exóticos con múltiples propiedades,
incluso hay gente que estudia
la energía oscura del universo,
que podríamos intentar aprovechar.
El problema es que esas cosas
tampoco van a resolver el problema,
por la simple razón de que cualquier
sistema en el que estemos pensando
va a tardar como mínimo
30, 40 o 50 años en estar a punto.
El problema es que no tenemos
ni 30 ni 40 ni 50 años,
tenemos mucho menos tiempo,
tenemos el problema ahora mismo
y tenemos que darle una solución
en este mismo momento.
No podemos esperar una solución milagrosa,
que como en una película de Hollywood,
resuelva la situación,
tenemos que encarar el problema
en este preciso instante.
Y todo esto lo tenemos que hacer
en una situación
en la que tenemos problemas
ambientales muy serios.
Pensad que el planeta Tierra
para absorber todo el CO2
que hemos enviado a la atmósfera
necesitará por lo menos un milenio más,
suponiendo que paráramos ahora mismo
de emitir todo el CO2 que emitimos.
Pero es solo uno más de los problemas
ambientales que tenemos.
También tenemos problemas con
los plásticos, los metales pesados,
el agua, la polución del aire, la sexta
gran extinción de los seres vivos...
Tenemos que hacer frente
a todos estos problemas
con menos energía
que la que tenemos ahora.
Corrijo: Cada vez con menos energía.
Cada año tendremos menos energía
para hacer frente a un montón de problemas
que requieren una intervención
decidida y urgente.
Todo esto va a ser bastante
complicado de lidiar,
así que aprovechemos que aquí
tenemos aire acondicionado,
porque quizá en los próximos años
no vamos a tenerlo.
Tras lo que he dicho,
la conclusión parece clara:
la cosa no pinta nada bien.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Cuando hablo estas cosas,
la gente me dice que parece Mad Max.
Y este es el gran daño que hace
el cine de palomitas, de catástrofes,
que al final parece ser
que solo tenemos 4 o 5 clichés
para describir las cosas.
Si hablamos de un futuro en el que todo
va muy bien gracias a la tecnología,
parece Star Wars o Regreso al futuro,
y si hablamos de que habrán
problemas en el futuro
parece Armageddon o Mad Max.
La realidad es que si examinamos
la historia de la humanidad
cuando hubo una civilización
en una situación como la nuestra,
porque no es tan extraño
como nos pueda parecer
sino más bien algo repetido,
las cosas no se solucionan
mediante un héroe
o una situación
completamente extraordinaria.
Generalmente, que se resuelva el problema
depende de que se tomen las decisiones
adecuadas o equivocadas
para seguir adelante.
Si uno toma las decisiones equivocadas,
a lo largo de la historia, que sepamos,
ha habido 26 civilizaciones humanas
que han colapsado antes que nosotros.
Nosotros solamente
seríamos la 27ª en hacerlo,
con la única diferencia que
sería la primera que es global.
De todas maneras, también podemos
tomar las decisiones adecuadas
y evitar los problemas,
pero esto al cine no le gusta,
porque imaginad
que hicieran una película
en la que la gente ahorra agua,
comparte electrodomésticos
y medios de transporte,
(Risas)
trabaja localmente, cuida los bosques,
a los 15 minutos seguro
que la sala está vacía,
esto no le interesa a nadie.
Y el cine por eso tiene una
fijación con el colapso.
Pero es muy importante darse cuenta
de que el colapso es un daño
siempre autoinfligido,
las sociedades, cuando colapsan,
es porque han decidido colapsar.
Lo han decidido probablemente
de manera inconsciente, pero deliberada.
Las sociedades colapsan por motivos
religiosos, políticos, de orgullo patrio,
por cabezonería...
Pero realmente siempre es una decisión.
El colapso siempre es algo evitable.
Y de la misma manera,
uno puede elegir no colapsar.
Y para elegir no colapsar
es bastante sencillo
simplemente deja de hacer
aquellas cosas que no te convienen,
aquello que te hace mal.
Nosotros, en la situación actual
con toda la tecnología
y el conocimiento científico que tenemos
podríamos proporcionar unas
condiciones de vida muy buenas
a todos los habitantes del planeta
consumiendo mucha menos energía,
pero habría que cambiar todo
el sistema económico y social.
El gran problema es que en este momento
estamos escogiendo, de manera inconsciente
pero deliberada, colapsar.
Estamos escogiendo ese camino.
Y este es el motivo por el
que he venido aquí hoy.
He venido aquí a hablaros de un cambio.
De un cambio que no es que sea necesario,
es que es inevitable.
Nuestra sociedad va a
cambiar en los próximos años
y va a cambiar de una manera radical.
Continuar haciendo las cosas como
las estamos haciendo actualmente
simplemente no es una opción.
No es algo que podamos escoger.
No va a pasar.
Sin embargo, sí que podemos escoger cosas.
Podemos escoger en qué dirección
queremos ir y a dónde queremos llegar.
Básicamente, es como escoger
entre el cielo y el infierno.
El infierno lo pueden imaginar,
es el colapso absoluto de la civilización
el abandono de las ciudades,
mortandad masiva
y en última instancia la ley de la
jungla para los supervivientes,
que sería bastante peor,
incluso, que Mad Max.
El cielo tampoco es exactamente
como nos lo explican.
El cielo al que podremos llegar
no será uno en que nos salve
un gran milagro tecnológico,
una tecnología que no existe a día de hoy.
Nada nos sacará del atolladero
en que nos hemos metido.
Lo que hay que hacer, es conseguir
un sistema económico y social
que no requiera del crecimiento infinito
en un planeta que es finito.
¿Hay que decrecer? Sí, hay que reducir
la presión que estamos ejerciendo
sobre nuestros recursos naturales
y sobre la capacidad que tiene el planeta
de regenerar los residuos que generamos.
Hay que redistribuir la riqueza para
garantizar la igualdad social.
Hay que localizar el trabajo,
conseguir que la gente tenga trabajo
aunque no haya crecimiento económico.
Y por encima de todo,
hay que eliminar el interés compuesto,
el pago de deuda con interés,
porque es lo que empuja siempre
a la economía a crecer,
lo que hace que sea
necesario el crecimiento.
Si entendemos estas cosas,
si adoptamos los cambios
que realmente son necesarios,
la ciencia y la tecnología
nos van a ayudar,
nos darán los medios que
realmente ya están ahí
para hacer lo que necesitamos hacer,
porque en última instancia,
el cambio que necesitamos hacer,
el problema que tenemos que resolver,
no es un problema
ni científico ni tecnológico,
es un problema social.
Los ciudadanos tienen que
abordar este cambio, sí,
pero sobre todo deben abordarlo
los gobiernos y las grandes empresas,
y el primer paso es reconocer
que tenemos un problema
y que necesitamos cambiar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)